The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So welcome
back to 6.890.
Today we have the
first of two guest
lectures by Costis Daskalakis
about PPAD completeness.
Take it away, Costis.
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: OK.
Thanks for the invitation
to talk about PPAD.
This is sort of an unusual class
if you haven't seen it before.
So part of the
lecture is to describe
the class and the motivation
behind this definition.
If I start with the definition
itself, it may seem weird.
So instead, I want to
provide some motivation
about the definition.
And then sort of towards
the end of the lecture,
we're going to see
the definition.
We're also going to see our
first PPAD complete problem
in the end of this lecture.
And the next lecture, I'm
going to describe more natural,
if you want, problems
about PPAD complete.
OK.
So the motivation for
me looking at this class
is some beautiful theorems
in game theory, economics,
and topology, namely Nash's
theorem, Brouwer's theorem,
and Sperner's theorem.
And I want to describe
those theorems
before I get into the
computational complexity
of the resulting problems.
So let me start
with Nash's theorem.
So this table represents a
game between two players.
The rows correspond
to the strategies
available to the blue player.
And the columns correspond
to the strategies
available to the column player.
And then every box in this
table writes down the playoffs
that the two players
get if they chose
the corresponding strategies.
In particular-- so this
is a penalty shot game.
If the goalie dives left,
and the kicker shoots right,
then the goalie loses a point.
The kicker gets a point.
More generally, in
a game, you have
to specify the players n,
the number of players n,
the set of players n.
Then for every
player p, you have
to specify the set of strategies
available to this player.
And also for every
player p, you have
to describe a payoff function
Up that maps the strategies
of everybody to the reals.
So in particular, so Up of
a collection of strategies
for all the players
corresponds to the payoff
that player p gets if
the players chooses
these strategies from
the corresponding sets.
That's a general
definition of a game.
But in that picture, I
have a two player game
with two strategies per
player for simplicity.
Now what game theory
studies and tries to predict
is what happens when two
players interact in the way
described by a payoff
table and have developed
various notions of
equilibrium that
may arise as a result
of this interaction.
The one that is of particular
interest to us in this lecture
is what is called the
Nash equilibrium, which
is a pair of randomized
strategies for the two
players of the game
such that none of them
has incentive to change
their strategy given
the strategy of
the other player.
In this particular example,
the Nash equilibrium,
which is actually
the unique one--
a Nash equilibrium which is
the unique one of this game
is for both players to
uniformly randomly play each
of their available strategies.
And it's quite easy to check
that this is a Nash equilibrium
because given-- so for from
the kicker's perspective, given
that the goalie uniformly
randomly dives left or right,
the expected payoff from
shooting left or right
is exactly 0.
So in particular, any
complex combination
of these two strategies
has an expected pay of 0.
And he cannot improve it by
changing the mixing weights
in any way.
So given what the
goalie is doing,
it's in the best interest of
the kicker to play half, half.
And vice versa.
You can do the same calculation
from the goalie's perspective.
And given what the
kicker is doing,
the goalie cannot improve
his expected payoff.
So more generally,
in the general case,
every player chooses
a randomized strategy.
A randomized strategy is a
distribution over the strategy
set of the players.
So it's going to be--
with this symbol,
I represent the collection of
distributions over the set.
And I can extend this
function to distributions.
So let's call this the
extension of that function
to distributions.
When I get as input a collection
of mixed strategies, what
I'm going to do is I'm going
to look at the expectation
where every-- according to
these strategies, this s1
drawn from x1, s2 drawn from
x2 and so on and so forth,
sn drawn from xn.
I'm going to look at
the expected utility
under strategies, actions
that are chosen according
to this randomization.
So that's the expected
utility of player p
if players choose
these mixed strategies.
And Nash equilibrium in general
has a definition, a collection,
x1, x2, et cetera,
of mixed strategies
is a Nash equilibrium
if and only
if for every player p, the
expected utility that p gets
by playing this strategy is at
least as good as the expected
utility he would get if he
switched to something else
for any other mixed strategy
he could possibly play.
OK?
So if none of the other players
change their strategies,
there's no alternative
mixed strategy
for this player that
may improve his payoff.
So if that's simultaneously
true for all players,
then that collection is
called the Nash equilibrium.
And that example is
just a special case
of this definition.
Any questions about what
a Nash equilibrium is?
OK.
Now there are games
and games, right?
And this game is a
particularly simple one.
First of all, it has two
players and two strategies.
But also it's very
symmetric in some sense.
If I look at every
square of this table,
the sum of payoffs
in each square is 0.
These types of games are called
two player zero-sum games.
And the existence of
equilibrium in these games
was shown by von Neumann.
So von Neumann showed that
any two players zero-sum game
has such an equilibrium.
I mean, a priori, it's not
clear if in a given game
there is a collection
of strategies
that are a Nash equilibrium.
The first one to
establish such a result
was von Neumann in the '20s, who
showed that if a game has two
players, and it's
a zero-sum game,
then there is always an
equilibrium in that game.
By the way, the equilibrium
wasn't called Nash equilibrium
at the time, because
Nash wasn't around.
It is known as the
minmax equilibrium.
And in fact, later on when
Dantzig was developing
linear programming duality
together with von Neumann,
they realized that this
theorem is actually implied
by the strong LP duality.
They also noticed that
using linear programming,
you can compute equilibria
in these types of games.
In fact now-- but that
took many years more.
We know that this statement
and strong LP duality
are actually equivalent
mathematical statements.
OK.
So the existence of equilibrium
in two player zero-sum games
is equivalent to linear
programming duality.
All right?
But how about general games?
What happens if I go to
this table, and I change it?
Or I consider a game with
more than two players?
So what happens, for example, if
I change this game in this way?
Now I gave a big
advantage to the goalie
in the left, left
choice of strategies.
Now before Nash was
around, it was unclear
if a general game has
a Nash equilibrium.
This is what Nash established
in his celebrated paper.
Nash showed that any
game, any finite game
has a mixed Nash equilibrium.
So a Nash equilibrium
and equilibrium
in randomized strategies.
Unfortunately,
what is not known--
in this particular example,
this is the Nash equilibrium.
You can verify that this is
actually a Nash equilibrium,
what I'm showing there.
But the point of the
slide is that there
is a qualitative difference
when you go from two players
zero-sum games to general games.
In 60 or so years of work
after Nash's theorem,
we have no proof
using LP duality.
And we have no polynomial
time algorithms
for finding equilibria
in general games.
So part of this
lecture is to try
to understand the computational
complexity of this problem.
Given a game, how hard is it
to find a Nash equilibrium?
OK.
So that's problem number
one that I want to consider.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So the thing that
Nash proved, every game
refers to any number
of players and--
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: Right.
Any finite number of
players, any strategy set,
any utility functions.
No matter how it
looks like, there's
always a Nash equilibrium.
OK?
Other questions?
This is, let's say, the actor
number one in this lecture.
So the second actor
is Brouwer's theorem,
which I want to illustrate
in the next few slides.
The statement of the
theorem is very simple.
It says that given
a function that
maps a convex and compact
subset of the Euclidean space
to itself-- so I don't know.
In this setting, compact means
basically closed and bounded.
So if you have a function
that maps a convex,
closed, and bounded subset
of Euclidean space to itself,
it must have a
point that doesn't
move under the function.
And I want to illustrate this
with a couple of examples.
And for my examples,
I'm going to choose
for D the disk, the unit disk.
I'm going to note that all
conditions are needed actually
for the theorem to be true.
If you remove any of these
things, closeness, convexity,
or bondedness,
the theorem fails.
So I'm going to do
a bunch of examples,
and you can think about
what may happen if you
remove one of these conditions.
So my first example is
to map the disk to itself
by just rotating the disk.
Now there is an
obvious fixed point
in this map, which is the
center, as you may imagine.
There's actually no
other fixed point.
What if I take this
disk, and I shrink it,
and then I shift it
somewhere inside it?
I don't know.
Maybe it takes a
little thinking,
but you should believe
me that there must be
a fixed point somewhere there.
Or a fixed point still exists
if I kind of crumble the disk
and move it.
As long as I don't tear it
apart, that's a continuous map.
And there's still a fixed point.
And you probably
colloquially have
heard that if I take
a map of Cambridge,
and I throw it on
the ground, then
there is a point on
the map that sits
on top of the corresponding
point that it represents.
This is a special
version of this theorem
because effectively when
I'm throwing a Cambridge
map to the ground, I define
a mapping from real points
to points in the map.
And by this theorem, there
is a point that doesn't move.
OK?
So that's what Brouwer's
theorem is saying.
And the proof of Nash
actually uses this theorem.
To show that the Nash
equilibrium exists,
what Nash did is he
used Brouwer's theorem.
And the next slide, I
want to illustrate the way
Nash gets to prove the Nash
equilibrium's existence
by using Brouwer's theorem.
And I'm going to restrict
myself to the simple game we
saw in the beginning,
the penalty shot game.
And as I said, for
this specific game,
you don't need Brouwer's
theorem to prove
the existence of equilibrium,
because this is a two player
zero-sum game, and you can even
do it with linear programming
duality.
But it's a simple
enough example that
will help illustrate the
proof of Nash's theorem.
So here's what Nash does.
He starts with a game.
And then he defines a continuous
function, in this case,
from the square to itself,
from the unit square to itself
in a way that the fixed
points of that function
are actually exactly
Nash equilibria.
The way the function
looks, where basically,
what is the square?
The square represents
the probability--
the horizontal line is
the probability by which
the kicker shoots right.
The vertical axis is
the probability by which
the goalie dives right.
And then the
function is basically
tracking which of
the two players
has incentive to
change his strategy
at every point in this quarter.
So in particular, let's
consider this square over here.
In this square, both
players play left.
And the kicker is
actually unhappy.
If both players play
left, the kicker
wants to increase
the probability
by which he is shooting right.
So this is what this
arrow represents.
So you want to increase
the probability over here.
Similarly, if you're here,
they play opposite actions.
Hence, the goalie wants to
change and so on and so forth.
What Nash is-- I'm not going
to write down Nash's function,
but intuitively, this
is what it tracks.
It tracks at every combination
of mixed strategies,
which players have
incentive to change
their actions,
their randomizations
and in which direction?
This is what Nash's
function does.
And in fact, to help
you a little bit,
I'm going to even
color the unit square,
depending on the direction
of the deviation.
So this is the
picture that I get.
It's very easy to locate
the fixed point as the point
where all colors meet.
And this is exactly half,
half, which is exactly
the Nash equilibrium over here.
This is a schematic
proof by picture.
So this is an illustration
of Nash's proof.
Any questions about Brouwer's
theorem or the proof?
OK.
The last actor-- so the last
actor is Sperner's lemma.
It's a lemma in combinatorics,
but it's very related
to topological statements.
So the lemma
considers-- there are
multiple versions of the lemma.
And I'm going to show it in
two dimensions on the square.
There are multi-dimensional
versions of the lemma.
But I'm going to restrict
myself to the plane.
And the lemma is going to
start with a triangulation
of the grid.
And I'm going to color
this triangulation
with three colors.
More generally, if
I'm in n dimensions,
I'm going to be coloring
things with n plus 1 colors.
Here I'm in two dimensions.
I'm coloring with three colors.
So the way I'm going to color
this square is the following.
First, I'm obliged to use
this coloring on the boundary.
Notice that this boundary
has the property that there
is no red color here.
There is no blue color here.
There is no yellow color here
on that edge of the grid.
But otherwise, I'm allowing you
to color the internal vertices
in whatever fashion you want.
All I want is to respect
the boundary coloring.
So Sperner's lemma
says that no matter how
you color the inside
of the square,
there is always a
tri-chromatic triangle.
In fact, it says something more.
It says that there is
always an odd number
of tri-chromatic triangles.
Can you see one in this picture?
AUDIENCE: I hope so.
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS:
You would hope so, right?
So there are five in this case.
Here they are.
And later in the--
I mean, I'm actually
going to show the proof
of Sperner's lemma
because it's instructive for my
purposes later in this lecture.
It's really remarkable.
I mean, a priori, I
mean maybe you believe
there's a tri-chromatic one.
But it's not at all.
Obviously, there should
be an odd number.
And the proof is actually
going to easily give also
the odd number as well.
So that's the lemma.
That's Sperner's lemma.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
where the legal coloring is?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: Yeah.
So the legal coloring
says that either
fix the color to be like this.
Or more generally, as long
as you don't use red here,
don't use yellow here, and not
use blue here, you're good.
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
the general statement.
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS:
The general definition
is that-- OK.
So we have this square.
There must be-- OK.
So more general, no
yellow in these vertices.
There should be no
blue on these vertices.
And there should be no red here.
That's the general statement.
As long as you
respect that, then
no matter what you
do inside, there
is a tri-chromatic triangle.
Or you could just fix
the coloring to be that.
It doesn't really matter.
In fact, if you have
such a coloring,
respecting these
three properties,
you can enlarge the
square by adding
an extra layer that has exactly
the coloring I'm showing here.
And you can notice that if
your original coloring respects
these properties, if I
add this specific coloring
in this extra layer, I'm
not going to be creating
any triangles in this layer.
So in fact, I can reduce
one instance to the other.
All right.
So this is the statement
of Sperner's lemma.
There is a multi-dimensional
version in n dimensions.
I'm using n plus 1 colors.
But I'm not going
to state it here.
Now again, I'm
going to hand wave
to actually show you how
Brouwer's theorem is actually
implied by Sperner's lemma.
So in fact, one proof
of Brouwer is actually
going through Sperner.
Here's the high level
proof of the argument.
Given a function-- I'm going
to do it on the square,
on the unit square
in two dimensions.
So suppose I'm given
a continuous function
from the square to itself,
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to prove for all
epsilons-- for all epsilons,
I'm going to show that there
exists an approximate fixed
point with
approximation epsilon.
using Sperner's lemma.
That's what I'm going to
do with Sperner's lemma.
And then I'm going to use
a compactness argument
to get this down to 0.
So I'm going to create in fact
a sequence of approximate fixed
points with smaller
and smaller epsilons.
And I'm going to use
compactness-- remember,
this is a compact set--
to argue that there
is an exact fixed point.
So Sperner's lemma can be
used for this first part
of the proof.
And roughly speaking, the way
it's used is the following.
What you do is you first
triangulate the square.
And the diameter
of your triangles,
which is very rough in this
picture-- the diameter of this
will depend on the constant
of absolute continuity
of your function.
So if the function is
ellipsis, it's just
going to depend on epsilon
and the ellipsis constant.
So depending on the
ellipsisness of the function,
there's going to be a
finer triangulation.
Now having
triangulated the square
and adding this
extra layer outside,
you're going to color the
vertices that are inside
depending on the direction
of the displacements
f of x minus x, using
exactly the same coloring
schema I showed you earlier
for the illustration of how
Nash showed the existence
of equilibria using Brouwer.
So I'm going to color
those internal vertices
using this coloring scheme,
depending on the directions.
And then for the extra layer
that I added on the outside,
I will just use my
standard coloring.
Now what's cool with the
way I chose my colors here--
I mean, this is my
standard coloring,
except I have permuted
the names of colors.
Sorry about that.
I think, you know, red took
the role of blue and stuff
like that.
But it doesn't really matter.
What is cool about
the way I chose
my colors is that
if a point is here,
I know that is not going
to be using-- essentially,
it can only be in the boundary
between red and yellow.
But if you're here, and
the displacement is yellow,
you're going to
be going outside.
That's a bad thing.
So the way I chose
my colors, I know
that some property like
this is going to happen.
Some of the edges
of this cube are
going to be missing
some of the colors.
For example, here, there is no
red, because if there were red,
then I would have to be
going down outside my square.
And my function is mapping
the square to itself.
So that can't happen.
Similarly, over here
I cannot have a yellow
and so on and so forth.
So that's going to be a valid
instance of Sperner's lemma.
And by Sperner, there is
a tri-chromatic triangle
in this scenario.
Here it is.
You could see the fixed
point at the back.
That's a coincidence
actually because I'm going
to do the compactness after.
But I'm going to
do Sperner's lemma.
Now a tri-chromatic
triangle is actually
going to-- one of the corners of
the tri-chromatic triangle will
have this property if you choose
the diameter of your triangles
to be-- it's correctly chosen.
So that's, roughly speaking,
how the proof works.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The fact that
Sperner's lemma shows
that there's an odd
number of such triangles
means there's an odd number
of [INAUDIBLE] not carry over?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS:
This carries over,
except in degenerate games
where it doesn't hold.
But in a non-degenerate
case, it will hold,
not by direct use of Sperner's.
Because Sperner is always going
to go through approximations.
So there is another way to
prove the existence of Nash
equilibria in two player
games using what is called
the Lemke-Howson algorithm.
and this Lemke-Howson
algorithm has a similar flavor
as Sperner.
And it also has an odd
number of solutions.
And this is still true.
So for two player
games, it is still true
that there is an odd
number of solutions
if the game is non-degenerate.
I'm not sure what's the
status of multiplayer games,
because then there are
irrational solutions.
So combinatorics give you
approximations but not
exact fixed points.
Yeah?
So yeah.
So the fact that there is
an odd number of solutions
calls for this combinatorial
problem, Sperner.
But after you do compactness,
then I don't know what happens.
So all bets are off.
But for the specific
case of two player games,
there is an alternative
proof that carries over.
OK?
Cool.
OK.
So these are the three problems
that I'm interested in.
And now it's the
time where I'm going
to get into a bit of
complex theory discussion.
And in fact, this
complex theory discussion
will lead to the fact that NP,
the standard concept that we
use for understanding
complexity,
is not sufficient to
address these problems.
And that will motivate PPAD.
But first of all, let me give
intuition about why Sperner
hard.
And here's the situation
I want to be looking at.
So I want to be looking at
the grid of size 2 to the n.
So in particular, I'm
not going to be drawing
the grid explicitly for you.
And I'm not going to
be listing the colors
of the internal
vertices as a list.
So what I want to do
is I want to create
a succinct description of a
coloring of an exponentially
large instance in
the following way.
So I'm going to be imagining
the existence of this grid
with its boundary colored
in this specific way.
And what I'm going
to give you is I'm
going to give you a
circuit that takes
as input the coordinates of
points inside this square
and outputs a color.
Now so this circuit
only decides the colors
of the vertices inside.
And I fix the colors
of those vertices
to be what is shown
in the picture.
Thus, that's a succinct
description of a coloring of 2
to the 2n vertices.
And this coloring satisfies the
conditions of Sperner's lemma.
In particular, there is
a tri-chromatic triangle.
And what the problem
is asking you to do
is to find such a triangle.
Describing this
triangle can be done
with polynomials complexity
because all you need to do
is to output the coordinates
of the three points
participating in the triangle.
So the output
description-- I'm not
asking you to do
something crazy, right?
So the output can be
described in polynomial size.
The input-- and
what's problematic
with this problem
is that the size
of the graph we're
working with is
exponential in the input size.
So this circuit
has n input bits.
So this graph is in
principle exponentially
large in the description
of the problem.
So in particular, I cannot just
go and check every triangle
about whether it is
tri-chromatic or not.
I have to do something
smarter to solve this problem.
And in fact, we have no other--
essentially, no smart solutions
to this problem.
OK.
So that Sperner's lemma.
That's a way to define
the computational version
of Sperner's lemma.
Similarly, you can
define Nash and Brouwer.
I'm only going to define Nash.
Brouwer is a bit
more complicated.
So in the Nash
problem, I'm giving
a game which is described
by the number of players,
the strategy sets,
which I enumerate,
and the utility
functions of all players.
This is the product
of all the sets.
And I'm also giving you an
approximation requirement
epsilon.
And I'm going to comment
on that in a second.
What I want you to do is
to find an epsilon Nash
equilibrium of this game.
Now what's an epsilon Nash
equilibrium of the game?
An epsilon Nash equilibrium is
a collection of mixed strategies
such that no player has more
than an epsilon incentive
to change his strategy.
So in this definition here, I
would add a minus epsilon here
to make it an epsilon
Nash equilibrium.
So I have not more than
an epsilon incentive
to change my mixed strategy.
That's what an epsilon
Nash equilibrium is.
Now why did I have to define
the problem in this way?
There's a specific
complex theoretic reason
why I'm defining my problem
as an epsilon Nash instead
of an exact Nash equilibrium.
What is that reason?
Yeah
AUDIENCE: Maybe the exact Nash
equilibrium makes [INAUDIBLE].
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: Right.
So Nash's proof is via
Brouwer's theorem, which
is a topological statement.
And there's no guarantee
that the output-- if I
were to omit this epsilon
from this definition,
there's no guarantee that the
output has polynomial size
complexity.
Maybe a Nash equilibrium
is comprised of irrational
numbers, which I cannot specify.
Maybe it's not even algebraic.
Who knows?
But it is algebraic.
So approximations
are in fact-- Nash,
his paper in '51, not the
original one but the one that
appeared a year later.
He actually provides an
example of a three player game
that only has
irrational equilibria.
So I'm working with epsilons
to avoid this issue.
Coming back to two
player games, you
can actually show
that any two player
game has a rational equilibrium
whose probabilities are
of polynomial complexity in
the description of the game.
So in this specific case
of two player games,
you can actually
omit the epsilon
if you want from the
description of this problem.
But for general
games, you add a third
to make this question
computationally meaningful.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it always
the case that there's
an equilibrium that's a root
of the polynomial bounded
complexity in the
description of the problem?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: I
believe this is true, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you
do the same thing?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS:
You could, yeah.
You could in principle do that.
I'm not going to define Brouwer.
But you can imagine in
Brouwer similar things.
You have to take care
of similar things
and define epsilon approximate
fixed points, et cetera.
Now let's look at NP.
The variant of NP
that I'm interested in
is that of search problems
in NP, so function NP.
I don't want to
bore you, but I'm
going to go through
the definitions.
So a search problem is
defined by a relation
of inputs and solutions
such that a pair x and y
is in this language
defined by this problem
if y is a solution to x.
So I expect you
to know all this.
And I'm going to go fast
through these definitions.
But what's important
here is this definition.
When do we say that
the problem is total?
We say the problem is
total if for every input
there is a y that is a
solution to the problem.
For example, Sperner's
problem is total
because for any instance
of Sperner's problem,
there is actually a solution.
For any input of this form,
you know by Sperner's lemma
that there is a solution.
So that problem is
a total problem.
Similarly, for every input
to Nash, there is a solution.
So these problems
are total problems.
Let's see.
OK.
Now a search problem is
an FNP, function of NP,
if there is a polynomial
time algorithm
and a polynomial function
so that two conditions are
satisfied.
First, if the algorithm
on input x and y is 1,
then and only then y
is a solution to x.
And also for every
input to the problem,
if there is a solution
to that instance,
then there is one whose size
is polynomial in the input
of the problem.
So you have solutions that
are polynomially large.
And so this is FNP.
And TFNP is the
class of problems
that contains all problems
in NP that are total.
And based on the previous
discussion, all the problems
we're interested in, Sperner,
Nash, and Brouwer, are TFNP.
Sorry.
TFNP.
Both in FNP but also in TFNP.
OK.
And I guess let me remind
you about FNP completeness.
A problem in FNP associated
with an algorithm
and a polynomial function
is poly-time reducible
to another one associated
with an algorithm
and a different bound.
If there exist two functions,
f and g, one of them
is mapping inputs to l
to inputs to l prime.
And also, you have
two properties.
And it's important to
look at these properties
carefully because they're
related to a point
that I want to make.
So for the reduction
to be valid,
you also need this property,
that for every x and y,
if the algorithm of problem l
prime on the transformed input
and y says 1, then you
can take that solution
and transform it into a
solution to the instance to l.
This is what it says.
Well, this one says that if
the transform instance has
no solution, then the
original instance also
shouldn't have any solution.
And a search problem is FNP
complete if it's both in FNP,
and every problem in FNP is
polynomial time reducible
to it.
And of course, finding
a satisfying assignment
is FNP complete.
But now we reached the
point that I want to make.
What I want to claim is that
I cannot possibly reduce SAT
to any of the problems
that I'm interested in.
In particular, I cannot show
that there's no Karp reduction
from SAT to any
of these problems.
And the reason is this property.
Recall, this property was saying
that for every input to problem
l, if the y' is a solution
to the transformed instance,
then I can convert that
solution to a solution
to the original instance.
But now if l is SAT, and
this is Sperner, then
no matter how you transform
the SAT instance to a Sperner
instance, there is going to be a
triangle that is tri-chromatic,
setting this to 1.
So I should be able to
then convert this triangle
to a satisfying assignment.
But what if those instances
are unsatisfiable?
That possibly cannot hold
if your two problems are SAT
and Sperner.
So there's no reduction.
There's no Karp reduction
from SAT to Sperner.
So you can't show any of these
problems for that matter.
So you cannot possibly argue
that these problems are FNP
complete.
Another thing you may try is to
get Turing reductions from SAT
to these problems.
But that has other issues.
It basically would imply
that NP equals co-NP.
So there's no way basically.
These types of problems
don't-- if you want type check,
they don't type check.
These are problems
that are total,
and these are problems who's
complexity really resides
with the fact that it's
hard to distinguish
satisfiable and
non-satisfiable instances.
So LP completeness is not the
right language, if you want.
It's not the right framework
to understand the complexity
of these problems.
And the exercise through
which we're going today--
and I think it's
instructive-- is
how to go about
characterizing problems
that don't fit into traditional
complexity theoretic
frameworks.
So in particular, what
I want to understand
is how to go about
defining a complexity
theory of total search
problems inside FNP.
Clearly, these problems
actually are inside FNP.
These are FNP problems.
They're TFNP problems.
So how do you go about coming
up with a complexity theory
of total search problems?
And the way you go
about it is to look
at the proof of existence of
solutions in these problems
and understand the combinatorial
underpinnings of the existence
argument.
So if you want the 100 feet
overview of the methodology
that I'm going to
follow, it's this.
First, I want to identify
the combinatorial argument
of existence responsible for
making all these problems
total problems.
And then I want to define
a complexity class inspired
by this argument of existence.
And the litmus
test of my approach
is if the resulting
complexity class actually
tidily characterizes the
complexity of these problems.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to show you the proof
for Sperner's lemma,
and that's going to inspire
the definition of PPAD.
So this is what I'm going to
do in the next few slides.
So here's the
statement of the lemma.
If your boundary
is legally colored,
then there is
always an odd number
of tri-chromatic triangles,
in particular at least one.
Let me try to prove it for you.
The first thing I'm
going to do says
I'm going to introduce
an artificial vertex
at the bottom left
of the square.
Here it is.
And I'm going to color it blue.
Now no matter how you
color the internal vertices
of this square,
because I have fixed
by coloring on the boundary
to be the one you see here
in this picture, I know that by
adding a blue vertex over here,
I'm creating an artificial
tri-chromatic triangle.
I'm going to call the triangle
the beginning of my walk.
And now I'm going to basically
define a walk in this grid.
Consider this is a big factory.
The factory is partitioned
into triangular rooms.
And I'm starting my walk in
this factory from this vertex
here, from this triangle here.
Now my walk is going to be
doing the following thing.
It's going to be going from
triangle to neighbouring .
Triangle and the transition
rule is the following.
I'm going to look
in the room I'm in,
and I'm going to try to
find a red-yellow door.
If I find such a door, I want
to try to cross it having red
on my left hand.
That's the rule of my walk.
Red-yellow doors.
I want to cross them
with red on my left.
That's important.
I meant to say
yellow on your left.
Sorry about that.
So let's go back
to this picture.
I created these artificial
triangle over here.
I knew it's going
to be tri-chromatic
because it only considers
vertices on the boundary.
And I have fixed the
coloring of the boundary
to be this specific one.
I know it's going to have a
red-yellow door which I can
cross having yellow on my left.
So let me cross that door.
Now I'm entering
into a new room.
In this particular
case, there's nothing
interesting about this
room because this still
touches the boundary.
So no matter how you color
the internal vertices,
you couldn't affect the
coloring of this boundary.
So it's also going to have a
red-yellow door, which I can
cross having yellow on my left.
And the interesting
business starts now.
I entered into a new room, and
depending on your coloring,
maybe it's already
tri-chromatic.
So how do you color
this into blue?
This would already be a
tri-chromatic triangle.
why?
Because you entered that room
through a red-yellow door,
and you encountered
a blue color.
What is cool about it though
is that if it's not blue,
then there's going
to be for sure
another door which you can cross
having yellow on your left.
In this particular
scenario, this was a yellow.
It wasn't a blue.
So this was not a
tri-chromatic triangle.
But because this was a
yellow, I enter a room
through a red-yellow
door, and I find a yellow.
There is for sure
another red-yellow
door I can cross having
yellow on my left.
So this is what I'm going to do.
And I'm going to keep
doing this until-- what
can go wrong, right?
So the claim that I want to make
is that if I keep doing this
procedure, I cannot
exit the factory.
For me to exit
the factory, there
has to be a door on the
boundary which I can
cross having yellow on my left.
Now because-- and that's where
the coloring of the boundary
becomes important.
Because I have fixed the
color of the boundary
to be the one you
see in this picture,
you can verify that there
is no red-yellow door
you can cross to go outside.
The only red-yellow door
that exists is this one.
But if you're inside, you cannot
cross it going to the outside
having yellow on your left.
And that's where having
left on your left hand side
is important.
This is the only
red-yellow door.
But you cannot cross
it going outside.
You can only cross
it going inside.
So you cannot exit the factory.
So your walk is
going to keep going.
And there are two
possibilities now.
So one is that it's
going to keep going.
And then it's going to
enter into a new room
through a red-yellow door,
and it's going to find a blue.
In that case, my
lemma is proven,
not the odd number, but at
least I've proven to you
there is at least one triangle
because I entered into a room.
I found a blue.
I entered through
a red-yellow door.
That's a proof of existence.
But there is one thing
that can go wrong, though.
What is that?
I can loop around.
So what I can do is I can--
so this is my factory.
I started over here.
I start wandering
around this factory.
And then I sort
of got into a room
that I had already
visited before.
And then I get into a
loop, and I go forever.
That's the problem
that may happen.
I claimed over there
that this cannot happen.
Why can it not happen?
AUDIENCE: Coloring.
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS:
Yeah, let's try to color it.
Let's zoom into here.
So this is a room that I
got into at the beginning
through a red-yellow door
having yellow on my left.
So originally, I
got into this room
like this having
yellow on my left.
Then I exited this room
through a red-yellow door
having yellow my left.
So this door, potentially
it was a red here.
So I exited this way.
But then I cannot possibly
enter through this door,
because that's a red-red door.
Or this could be a yellow, in
which case, I exited from here.
But still now I cannot
get back from that door,
because that's a
yellow-yellow door.
So this cannot happen.
So my walk cannot get back
into an already visited room,
and it cannot exit the factory.
So the only thing it
can do is just stop
because there's a finite number
of rooms in this factory.
But the only way it can stop
is if it finds a blue when
it enters a new room.
So that's the
proof of existence.
If you follow my
walk, indeed, you're
going to get into a
tri-chromatic triangle.
And this way, I finished
the first part of the claim.
Any questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The same argument
give you the odd number though?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS:
It does, yeah.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: If you
find another one,
then it has to [INAUDIBLE].
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: Right.
Let's try to do that.
So let's start from
a different triangle.
Let's start from here.
But if I start
from here, there's
no red-yellow door I can follow.
So that doesn't
give me anything.
But let's start
with somewhere where
there are red-yellow doors.
So let's start with here.
Now I can follow the
same kind of business.
I can get into doors.
I can cross red-yellow doors
having yellow on my left.
In this case, that got me
into a tri-chromatic triangle.
Now let me go back here and
actually do the word backwards,
so have it going backwards,
having yellow on my left.
So this is what happens.
So I found a
tri-chromatic triangle.
And these actually
came in pairs.
The fact that this gave me a
tri-chromatic triangle must
mean that this has to give you
another one because by the same
token, I cannot sort of get
into a loop while going back.
On the other hand,
there are some triangles
where that would give you-- so
you get another pair over here.
These don't give you anything,
because if you start here,
you don't move.
But here you can get loops.
If you start from the inside,
you can get into a loop.
The point is that all
triangles come in pairs,
except for this walk, which
started with an artificial one.
So all tri-chromatic
triangles come in pairs,
except for the tri-chromatic
triangle that I
found in my original walk.
Thereby, there is an
odd number of those.
So it's kind of-- its
pretty cool, right?
Let me actually try to abstract
this proof a little bit
and sort of focus more onto the
core argument why this happens.
So here's what I did, really.
So this is my
space of triangles.
This is my set of triangles.
I want to define a graph where
the vertices are the triangles.
And the adjacency of
triangles-- so two triangles
are connected if
they share a door,
and you can go from one
triangle into the other one
through this door having
yellow on your left.
So for this reason, all vertices
have out degree and in degree
at most 1 because every
triangle-- no matter how it's
colored-- has at most
one red-yellow door
which you can cross having
yellow on your left to go out.
And it has at most
one door which
you can cross having yellow
on your left going in.
So just the minute definition
of my transition rule,
which was cross a red-yellow
door having yellow
on your left, defined
a graph on the set
of triangles that has in degree
and out degree at most 1.
Now a graph with in degree
and out degree at most 1
is a very simple type of graph.
It looks like this.
It's a bunch of
isolated vertices,
a bunch of directed cycles,
and a bunch of directed paths.
And in fact, the way I
define my position rule,
you could check that all degree
1 nodes must be tri-chromatic.
If you're tri-chromatic,
there is either
one door you can exit,
one red-yellow door
you can exit having
yellow on your left.
Or depending on how the
coloring is, one door
you can use to enter
the triangle having
yellow on your left.
So only tri-chromatic triangles
can have total degree 1.
Isolated vertices are those who
don't have red-yellow doors.
And degree 2 are those who
have two doors, one with which
you can exit having yellow
on your left and one
with which you can enter
having yellow on your left.
So what I want to summarize
is that the mere definition
of my transition rule
defines this graph in a way
that all these unbalanced
vertices are solutions
to the Sperner problem.
All the vertices were solutions
And in fact, one
solution was artificial
because it was that triangle
that I created by adding
the extra node outside.
So all degree 1 vertices
are real solutions,
except one of them.
And by the structure
of the graph
then, there has to be an
odd number of solutions.
This is implied.
So to summarize,
the mere description
of my transition rule
defines this graph in a way
that all unbalanced
vertices are solutions.
And because these have to
come in pairs by parity,
there is an even
number of solutions.
Except one was artificial.
So hence, there is an
odd number of solutions.
So in particular,
what I want to argue
is that all these very
beautiful, very interesting
theorems that I showed
in the beginning,
Nash, Brouwer, and Sperner--
the real argument of existence,
besides sort of
mathematical work,
mathematical
obfuscation, if you want,
is this trivial statement
in combinatorics.
If you have a directed graph
with some unbalanced vertex,
then there must be
another unbalanced vertex.
You obviously know this theorem.
The proof of this
theorem is pretty clear.
If you have a directed
graph where some node has
a different number of
outgoing and ingoing edges,
then there has to be
another such node.
And effectively,
what I did over here
is I described a
directed graph, and I
identified this artificial
vertex, which was unbalanced.
It only had an ongoing
edge but no incoming edge.
And by parity, I knew there
must exist another one.
So in fact, I didn't even
have to use my walk argument
and stuff.
All I had to claim is
that the mere definition
of my transition rule
defined this directed graph.
And this directed graph
had some unbalanced vertex.
And I know that
somewhere in this graph,
there has to be another
unbalanced vertex.
But all I'm saying is
that the core of it
is this trivial lemma.
And now your question will
be, well, what the heck?
This lemma is trivial.
So we took so many
algorithms, Karger's class
and so on and so forth.
We've worked with graphs.
We know how to identify
these things, right?
Given a directed graph,
it's trivial to find
an unbalanced vertex.
But the point is that
you can sometimes
define exponentially
large graphs succinctly.
And you can ask people to
find your unbalanced vertices
in exponentially large graphs.
So that's what PPAD is about.
In fact, if I give
you a Sperner instance
by providing you a
circuit, we'd only
be working with
exponentially many triangles
in the description
of the circuit.
So that's why the
problem is difficult.
The problem is difficult because
the guy we're working with
is exponentially large in the
description of the problem,
of the instance.
So the PPAD class is trying
to capture this structure.
And we're right about
the point where I'm going
to define the class formally.
So you ready for this?
Oops.
OK.
The PPAD class, defined
by Papadimitriou
in the '90s-- actually,
this is the general version
of the paper.
The PPAD class is giving you
an exponentially large graph.
The vertex set of the
graph is 0, 1 to the n.
The graph is specified
in a weird way.
I'm going to give
you two circuits that
get an n input bit, and n bit
input and have an n bit output.
And using these two
circuits, I define
an edge between a string
and another string
if a weird condition
is satisfied.
So now we directed
that from v1 to v2
if this condition is satisfied.
Let me try to parse
these symbols there.
But before that, let
me call this circuit
the possible previous circuit.
And let me call this circuit
the possible next circuit.
Now this circuit
takes as input string,
and it outputs a candidate
neighbor of that string.
And similarly, this-- sorry, a
candidate father of the string.
And takes as input
a string and outputs
a possible child of the string.
And I only established an edge,
a directed edge from string v1
to string v2 if string v2
believes that its father is v1,
and v1 believes that
its child is v2.
If they agree on their sort
of parenthood relationship,
I add this edge.
OK?
Now you may ask
me, what the heck?
Why didn't you just define
this graph in a different way?
Why did you have to
have this possible child
and possible father
relationship and describe
the graph in this way?
And the answer to
this question is
that no matter-- so the
answer to this question
is, no matter what
circuit you give me,
that always defines your graph
with a very specific property
that we're going to
see in the next slide.
Back to the definition.
So I'm going to explain
the intuition behind this.
But back to the
definition, describe
an exponentially large graph
by giving these two circuits.
And I establish the
edges between nodes
only if this condition is true.
And what I'll ask you
to do is the following.
Given these two circuits, if
the all 0 string is unbalanced
and gives an exponentially
large graph that I defined,
then I'll ask you to find
another unbalanced node, which
by parity exists.
If the 0 string is unbalanced in
this exponentially large graph,
then by parity
argument, there must
be another unbalanced node.
I'm asking you to find it.
That's the definition of
this end of the line problem.
And PPAD is the
class of all problems
that are in FNP
that are poly-time
reducible to this problem.
Now this sounds weird.
So let me show you how the graph
defined by these two circuits
looks like.
And this will be
hopefully familiar.
So I'm copying here the
condition for putting
an edge between two strings.
The set of things I'm
looking at is 0, 1 to the n.
This is the condition for when
I put an edge from string v1
to string v2.
Now notice that by
definition, every string
has at most one possible child.
And every string has at
most one possible father.
So the in degrees and
out degrees of this graph
are at most 1.
So I'm implicitly describing
a graph that looks like this.
And what I ask you to do
is to check the following.
I ask you to check
if 0, the 0 string,
is unbalanced, meaning it either
has a father but not a child.
Or it has a child
but not a father.
If it's balanced, you
don't need to do any work.
But if it's unbalanced, which
is easy to check locally--
you just query the candidate
next child and check
if that child believes that 0
is its father or vice versa.
If 0 to the n is
unbalanced, then by parity,
because the graph
looks like this,
there must be some other
unbalanced vertex, at least
one.
And I'm asking
you to find me any
of these unbalanced vertices.
So in particular, you don't need
to find the unbalanced vertex
that's in the other end of the
path that starts at 0 to the n
or finishes at 0 to the n.
You can give me any of the
other unbalanced vertices
if there are any.
But by parity, I
know that there is
at least one unbalanced vertex.
So PPAD is this problem.
I describe an
exponentially large graph
by giving you two circuits.
Now no matter what
circuits I gave you,
I know the graph
looks like this.
Now in this graph, if 0
to the n is unbalanced--
if a 0 string is
unbalanced, you know
that there must be
another unbalanced vertex.
Any of them is good as a
solution to the problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So how then do
we know that 0 to the n
doesn't point to a
previous other string that
points to 0 to the n?
How do we know that 0 to the n--
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: So
in that-- no, it can happen.
It could be that
this is 0 to the n.
It has a child that believes
that this is its father.
And also, v believes that
0 to the n is its child.
And 0 to the n believes
that this is the father.
This creates a 0 to the
n which is balanced.
In that case, you don't
need to do any work.
So the statement
of the problem is
asking you to do work only
if 0 to the n is unbalanced.
So end of the line
tells you if 0 to the n
is unbalanced, which you can
trivially check locally-- you
don't need to look
at the whole graph
to decide whether 0 to
the n is balanced or not.
So to decide whether 0
to the n is balanced,
you need four queries.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you have
an exponentially long segment?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS:
Yeah, but the point
is-- that's the whole point.
So if I query-- if v--
AUDIENCE: I see.
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: is the
possible parent of 0 to the n,
and u is the possible
child of 0 to the n,
then the state of the
world could be this.
It could be this.
Now if also this guy believes
that 0 to the n is his father,
I'm going to make
this edge solid.
That's the fourth query I'm
going to make to my circuits.
If this guy believes that
0 to the n is his father,
I'm going to also
make this edge solid.
If both are solid, then
0 to the n is balanced.
I don't need to do any work.
If this is missing, then
0 to the n unbalanced.
I need to do work and
so on and so forth.
OK?
But with four queries
to my circuits--
so in polynomial
time in particular
in the description of my input--
I can decide whether 0 to the n
is balanced or not.
And if it's unbalanced, then
I need to do a lot of work.
And in fact, we have no
better than exponential
bound for how long it
will take me to find
the other unbalanced node.
AUDIENCE: Can you make all
such graphs of this type
with small circuits?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: Mm-mm.
I mean, no.
I mean, you're asking, if I pick
an arbitrary exponential graph,
if it's always compressible
into polynomial size?
I mean, it depends on
how phrase the question.
So if you allow me to get a
huge p-- p is part of the input.
p is a part of the input.
So now if p is a
lookup table, that's
a trivial instance, actually.
So the instances that
are hard are those
where p is a succinct thing.
It's polynomially in n
size but still defines
an exponentially large graph.
If p is a huge thing,
a lookup table that
keeps track of all
connectivities of all vertices
with each other, we're getting
into algorithms territory,
where I give you an adjacency
list for every node.
So this is a purely
algorithmic problem
that we can trivially solve.
So if I get into the regime
where my p, my circuit
description, is polynomial
in the size of the graph,
that's an easy instance.
But if you're
asking the question,
can I always compress an
exponentially large graph
into two circuits, p and n,
that are polynomial in size,
then that's not the case.
OK.
So PPAD-- notice that this
end of the line problem
is in FNP because I can just
guess the unbalanced vertex,
different than the 0 string.
And I can check
easily if it's also
unbalanced with four queries.
So it is in FNP.
And I hope you believe me
that Sperner isn't PPAD,
because just the
proof of Sperner
was exactly the
same kind of thing.
So I succinctly
described this graph that
had exactly the same structure.
So really, what inspired
the definition of this class
is the proof of Sperner's lemma.
Now I sort of argued that you
can prove Brouwer via Sperner.
I gave this hand wave-y, high
level picture showing that.
And also Nash through Brouwer.
So in fact, PPAD definitely
contains the problems
that I'm interested in.
That was the litmus test.
The litmus test is I went
through this exercise
to define this class PPAD
based on the existence
proof of Sperner's lemma.
And I successful got all
these interesting problems
inside PPAD.
But the litmus test is--
the success of my exercise
is whether I get also
tight reductions.
So if I also get that
these problems are
as hard as any other
problem in PPAD,
now I can call my
thing successful.
So in particular, as an
example, the definition of NP
is that SAT is NP complete.
So NP was defined
with SAT in mind.
But it also captured exactly
the complexity of SAT.
So that was a
successful definition
of a complexity class.
So the litmus test for this
exercise that I went through
with you is whether
actually those problems
that I'm interested in
are also PPAD complete.
So what we showed with
Goldberg and Papadimitriou
a bunch of-- I guess
10 years ago almost--
is that actually the opposite
reductions are also true,
that all these problems are
computationally equivalent.
In fact, I didn't show that
these are equivalent to PPAD.
These were already known.
These results were already
known since Papadimitriou's
original paper,
that PPAD exactly
is equivalent to
Sperner and Brouwer.
What we show together
is that Nash also
is equivalent, is in the
same league of problems,
basically establishing
that all of these problems
are computationally equivalent.
Finding a Nash equilibrium
is a computational equivalent
to Sperner's lemma,
computationally equivalent
to any problem in PPAD
and so on and so forth.
And the high level
of the reduction--
I'm going to hand
wave about it--
is that we started this
generic PPAD instance.
And what we do is we envision
embedding this instance
into some geometry.
Because this a
combinatorial problem,
our goal eventually
is to reduce it
to Brouwer and to Nash, which
are continuous problems.
So the first thing we did is
we embed this graph into a cube
in a way that's sort of like
every path or cycle corresponds
to a path that moves
around this cube
without intersecting itself.
So this is the
first thing we do.
Then we find a way to solve
the resulting embedded PPAD
instance, reduce it to
a Sperner's instance.
And then in fact, the
core of the proof--
and I'm going to actually
talk about this more--
is to reduce this problem
into a problem that
asks you to evaluate
an arithmetic circuit.
Now after you get that PPAD
reduces to this evaluation
problem, it's really-- I call it
approximate arithmetic circuit
SAT.
So I'm going to get
into what this means.
But it's really a
satisfiability problem
for arithmetic circuits.
But after you get PPAD to
reduce to this problem,
it's easy to get to Nash and
all the other implications,
all the other known PPAD
completeness reductions
that people have established.
So what I want to describe is
what this problem is about.
It's the equivalent of circuit
SAT, which is NP complete.
This is called
arithmetic circuit SATs,
and I'm going to show
you what it means.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So in the
course of this reduction,
do we get to replay
our game for Nash,
like does this three
carry through to the--
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: Yes.
So you get actually two players.
You can get two player Nash.
Yeah.
So it establishes
that all games are--
if they're not two
player zero-sum,
they are PPAD complete.
So the input to the
problem is a circuit.
The circuit comprises two
kinds of nodes, viable nodes
and gates.
So gates are represented
with solid circles.
Viable nodes are with-- I
don't know-- empty circles.
So the viable nodes
are x1 through xn.
The gate's nodes
are g1 through gm.
Now the gates can--
I can choose gates
from the following
set of possible gates.
I'm going to explain what
these gates are meant to do.
But this is an assignment gate.
This is a plus addition gate.
This is a subtraction gate.
This is set equal
to a constant gate.
This is times a constant gate,
and this is a comparison gate.
The subtraction and
comparison gates
are non-symmetric
in their inputs.
So they have a special input
1 and a special input 2,
similarly for the
comparison gate.
And I also have directed
edges that connect variables
to gates and vice versa.
But there are no edges
between variables.
So there are no edges
between the gates.
And also, the loops are allowed.
That's important.
So you can have loops.
For example, in
this picture, you
have a loop between vertices.
And actually, there are
no inputs to the circuit.
In circuit SAT, you
want to set the input
so that the output is 1.
And you don't have loops.
You have a DAG.
And your gates are
just binary gates.
Here we're in a
different situation.
We don't have inputs.
Our gates can have loops.
And they're not binary.
They're arithmetic gates.
The goal is to assign 0,
1 values to the variables
so that the gate
constraints are satisfied.
So now what are the
gate constraints?
So the output of
an assignment gate
should equal the input
to the assignment gate.
If we have an addition gate,
the output of the addition gate
should be the sum of the
inputs, except everything
should line 0, 1.
So it's the minimum between
the sum of inputs and 1.
The subtraction gate is similar.
So the output to
the subtraction gate
is the difference of the inputs.
But you can't go below 0.
The set equal gate is-- set
equal to a constant gate
is sets y to ba.
But it doesn't allow
it to leave 0, 1.
And then multiply by
constant gate multiplies
the input with alpha, with a.
But also it doesn't allow
it to go below 0 or above 1.
And these are pretty
straightforward.
What is slightly weird
is the comparison gate,
which has a weird
behavior and actually must
have this behavior for the
problem to be PPAD complete.
You can show that.
The comparison
gate has to be a 1.
The output has to be a
1 if the first input is
bigger than the second input.
It has to be a 0 if this
first input is smaller.
But if they're equal,
it can be anything.
It's allowed to be anything.
Actually, if you think about
it as a continuous gate,
it cannot just jump from 0 to 1
without being able to take all
the intermediate values.
OK?
It can be anything.
Any value is allowed if
the inputs are equal.
So that's the
arithmetic circuit SAT
problem that is PPAD complete.
First of all, this
problem is total.
No matter what circuit
you write down,
I can prove to you
that there is always
an evaluation that works.
That's not a priori obvious.
It's not a priori obvious
that no matter what
circuit I describe
using these gates
has a satisfying assignment.
But I claim this is true.
I'm not going to show it to you.
It is true though.
And it must be true because this
problem belongs in this family
of PPAD complete problems.
So it has to also inherit
all the properties
that this class of
problems shares.
Now let's try to
work out the details
of what the computation is.
OK.
So I want to argue
that in this-- I
want to claim that the only
satisfying assignment is
that everything is
equal to 1/2 actually.
And let's try to verify it.
So suppose that a was
not-- actually, no.
I take that back.
So a must be 1/2, and b can be--
no, actually they're all 1/2.
Sorry, sorry.
They're all 1/2.
I don't take it back.
So let me try to argue that.
So suppose that a
was bigger than 1/2.
So c must be 1/2, right?
That's by the
condition of the gate.
This is set equal to 1/2.
So this must be 1/2.
That's obvious.
Now I claim that a cannot
be bigger than 1/2.
If a was bigger
than 1/2, then this
is bigger than this input
of the comparison gate.
So the comparison
gate would output a 0.
But this set equal
operation would
have to set this guy to be 0.
So 0 can't be bigger than 1/2.
Let's do the other direction.
Suppose a was smaller than 1/2.
If a was smaller than 1/2,
then the comparison gate
would [INAUDIBLE] 1.
This would set it to 1.
So how can 1 be
smaller than 1/2?
So the only possibility
is that it's actually 1/2.
And if it's 1/2 and 1/2,
then it's setting 1/2.
Because the inputs are equal
to the comparison gate,
you can set this to be anything.
So everything being 1/2
satisfies all the conditions
of the gates.
So that's the problem
we're trying to solve.
make The claim is that this
problem is PPAD complete.
And this problem is going to
be the starting point for all
our reduction next time, in
particular showing that Nash's
theorem is PPAD complete.
I want to add the last point.
After we published our
paper, Chen, Deng, and Teng
actually improved these
results to fuzzy gates.
So they-- actually, we
allowed in our original paper
exponential noise in
the outputs of the gate.
So this is an
easier problem now.
So I give you a circuit.
And I want you to find me
an assignment that satisfies
all gates approximately.
So now in the original
paper, we could accommodate
exponential noise in
the size of the input
and the fuzziness of the gates.
These guys showed
that you can even
accommodate any polynomial
noise, inverse polynomial noise
that you want.
And it's still PPAD complete.
That's an easier problem than
the exact problem obviously.
But in fact, they're
computationally
equivalent because they're
both PPAD complete.
So now next time,
what I'm going to show
is I'm going to use this problem
to show that Nash and market
equilibrium are PPAD complete.
I'm going to show that some
problems in combinatorics,
such as fractional hypergraph
matching and Scarf's lemma
are PPAD complete.
And then if we have
time, I'm going
to show you other
existence arguments that
give rise to different
interesting complexity classes.
AUDIENCE: Named
after Papadimitriou?
CONSTANTINOS DASKALAKIS: Yeah.
Many people ask that.
So it means polynomial parity
argument of directed graphs.
That's a good question.
Yeah.
I should have said that.
OK.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]